welcome back to new rockstars this is
the big question the show that gives you
too much information about how all
societies shutting down is scary but not
as scary has everyone suddenly flooding
back into it we're talking about
fictional world as always I'm Erik Bosse
here with Phil Polina how you doing man
I'm doing good real quick you just
reminded me that rewatching endgame
recently went so if you guys are doing
Ari watches with us too you'll notice
everything about endgame predicted
everything about coronavirus in
quarantine yes it's crazy like once you
rewatch it there are so many
similarities actually we can get into
some of them but there's so many more
when you actually watch it it's insane
they knew the whole time and they did
nothing whole time I'm sorry oh God
well they tried to warn us and our
infinity saga every watch did just reach
affinity war Thanos stuffs at half of
all life and yeah this blip that we're
now in it's gonna last another five
years until everything changes an
endgame it's it's familiar it's eerily
familiar so Phillip let's let's ask the
big question today what would the
real-world implications be not just for
the snap but for this awkward sudden
return of everyone who dusted let's get
some snap locations and some
duplications let's say no or fake words
that you love I think the second one
means the implications of the Bible we
are living in the biblical sense
I do I want to acknowledge a lot of
people can be like this topics been
covered before we know what happens or
plenty of Business Insider articles are
written about the implicator blah blah
blah first of all they're not caught up
all the way through far from home yeah
which I'm gonna try to be more caught up
but second they really boned it in on
the blip side of it so like Eric said it
gets way more interesting when you think
about everybody coming back and also why
Tony Stark may be a terrorism ladies and
gentlemen
we got him but look every week we just
accuse him of terrorism we'll get him
one you can accuse the dead of anything
it's legal that's right I can't see you
I'm gonna break this down into the snap
and the blip those are the official
terms like the snap is the dusting and
the blip is the return so we're gonna
start with the snap and talk about its
implications and I'm gonna try to skip
most of stuff that we already know like
for instance the snaps effect on the
environment we'll go through this just
really quick the environment would
thrive never been better dabbing
everywhere just being happy the whales
in the Hudson right it is the line we
learned in the endgame and that's
actually crazy Lee supposedly happening
right now people said that they saw
dolphins in the Venice canals which
sounds like alive but I really want to
go there so please come back it was a
dolphin wearing like a striped shirt
like with the gondola with a gun get oh
my god but what is totally true is that
that would totally would happen because
you might have just seen this this week
they announced the carbon emissions in
our world right now are down 17% which
might not sound like the craziest amount
but that's a fifth of the carbon
emissions are gone it is at the lowest
rate since World War two Wow after
everyone was nuked
yeah exactly which is also a terrible
time the world is able to finally like
take a breath and that would definitely
happen post snap so let's just move on
past the environment and move on to what
really moves the wheel the economy money
what we've learned in real life is that
some people put the economy above
everything so this is actually how we
would feel the effects of this nap
immediately post snap there would be a
lot of reshuffling of the economy there
would be a huge stock market crash it
would be a lot like what we saw as
coronavirus was kind of hitting hard we
immediately saw that the stock market
every day was getting worse it was
similar post 9/11 this is what happens
post tragedies a lot of people are just
worried that we're never gonna rebound
and if they're gonna lose a lot of money
but
then let's look into further
implications beyond that first day first
of all the workforce the available
people to work right now we're dealing
with very limited workforce that's in
those essential roles here's what's
interesting about the way danos did it
so he picks half of life to be gone and
he theoretically does it completely at
random unless he like really doesn't
like Al Gore or Ronald McDonald or
something to make sure like they're
definitely on the right side and you
could say that the genders is probably
roughly equal I believe there's a little
bit more women than men on earth but
basically it evens out to about 50/50
there so there's not gonna be much of an
issue there but each life no matter
their age counts the same and most
people alive today are between the ages
of 15 and 45 so that's the section that
would see the biggest loss the ratios
would be the same page thing but we
would lose millions and millions and
millions and millions of people between
15 and 45 and why that matters and why
doesn't matter that the ratio study
ain't but that we lose so much from that
sector is people between 15 and 45 are
the group that are primarily only able
to do certain jobs there are jobs at
there that are from before their time
and there are jobs that are probably
after their time but there's a group of
jobs this is kind of like our age people
we're somewhere between 15 and 45 and
we'll never tell what side of that we're
going to do and don't ask what one of us
is on one end and wonder what that means
is that people that are in this middle
group represent entire industries and so
the perfect example that I could think
of is the social media babysitters oh
yeah oh yeah no no no babysitters are
bound anyone can can watch a baby you
just sip a beer and make sure it's not
near a fire but Stacy from baby-sitters
club get done but voluntarily she was
already on her way out is what I'm
saying it suggested into sugar so okay
so that's the joke but social media
managers think you know right those are
people who there's no one over 45 who's
a social media manager and you know
there's not really like middle school
kids so they're they're more qualified
than the rest of us to do it so that's a
whole field that would just go
way and I mean you might think that
doesn't matter but I mean that's where
the quick 24-hour coupon codes get
shared
that's who apologizes when a company
says something really insensitive and
you know how many companies would be
making commercials about the snap where
it's like get a coke for your friend
who's gone or something you know like
there definitely would be a lot of
things to apologize for and so the
companies just wouldn't be able to
communicate with people as effectively
which would negatively impact them but
also let's remember that there are
certain jobs that only exist in that
older group the over 45 people who even
though it's a smaller group of people
there's not many people doing those jobs
so those are completely gone now - so we
got no Walmart greeters Oh completely
done and also nobody knows how to
operate a radio station it's just beyond
everyone where will you get your golden
oldies I believe every radio station is
just operated by eternals you're
wondering where the Eternals are they're
runnin KCRW with those smooth chocolaty
voices back to you Steve Inskeep Stevens
keep somewheres like ah my ears are
burning cuz they're on fire baby so
realistically though as I did more
research about these jobs and what
happens in these times of crises those
jobs honestly would be gone anyway
because the workforce would get
consolidated into the roles that are
considered essential so that means
somebody like a plastic surgeon would
have to just become a general
practitioner in ER to make up for the
missing doctors fancy chef would have to
become just like a general line cook to
make sure people are fed high-end escort
would have to settle for like sad saps
that just want someone to cry on so
basically this means entire sectors of
the economy and the workforce would just
be gone wiped out industries would be
gone but the government actually has a
record of how to behave in situations
like this and this is actually what I'm
very much hoping have legitimately
hoping happens now and the same thing
that happened in response to the Great
Depression and that's the New Deal so
the New Deal was an effort to pull
people out of the situation by giving
them opportunities and building new
industries that maybe weren't needed
before or investment in infrastructure
so what would probably happen is a lot
of people would second
in new jobs or suddenly there's a bunch
of openings because there's a snap
remember and there'd be lots of
investing in exciting new new things
pull new forms of insurance would
probably English assurance when do you
have too much dust in your laundry
filter where did all this extra dust
come from and also where's my husband
so in that end we actually would start
to kind of future-proof the economy and
it would take some leaps in industry so
that actually could be kind of
interesting and then if you stay on that
path you realize
danos wasn't totally wrong danos did
nothing wrong me immediately I knew we'd
get there gonna get there because it's
really easy to start doing that Matt
rent the cost of rent just plummets
there'd be a tremendous oversupply of
housing and people would also have more
disposable income because they don't
have dependent children to feed anymore
they don't have girlfriends to buy gifts
for and wives to buy gifts to make up
for the girlfriend yeah I got them hey
go go
also your general pay would actually go
up there are less people that are
qualified for your job now and a lot of
people have to get immediately promoted
because their boss turn to dust that's
right then it's didn't snap half the
money's away and since I assume we're
still in the old standard it's not like
he Goldfinger the the gold that our
money's based on oh I feel like I'm
getting this raw it's does the Federal
Reserve adjust interest rates and that
they print currency and inflation and
they just made a trillion dollars so
yeah I think you that's basically it
works like magic
got it great yes yes but you're
basically right the money is there for
the taking and people would start making
more money each one so as we kind of got
over the awkward phase people would
start buying things like crazy and a lot
of those things would be cheaper because
it'd be too much supply so it'd be like
clearance sales so the economy actually
would rebound in not too long moving on
the government responds so this I'm
learning based on the way things are
going right now a lot of the
government's initial response would be
what other government should we blame
for this yeah I thought about this and
actually it's pretty easy to think of
who would take all the blame
what condo oh yeah and it's not just
because of racist reasons you gotta
think about the timing there was a
secret country that nobody knew about
the had crazy weird technology that
nobody knew about and then some
essential battle that had ramifications
throughout the universe took place in
Wakanda and then suddenly half of her
everyone is gone it just seems kind of
convenient conspiracy theorist hundred
Alex Jones would be like driving in this
world yeah and then the MCs version
about shows is of course Jay jonah
Jameson here yeah all over this yeah for
sure and the fact that vision walked
around with one of these things in his
head and then they harbored and
sheltered this piece of crap in their
country and lured Thanos to earth and
that Street food and that hiding that
Street but you know if they got a taste
of that street food they might not be so
good the secret ingredient is vibranium
they just sprinkle very good taste great
it makes my teeth itch not the
heart-shaped herb that's edible vibrate
so our country would probably have
issues with another country in a lot of
countries maybe there'd be a little bit
of shake up but it doesn't matter
because democracy would die because if
you think about it voting doesn't
actually do well on the other side of a
crisis that there's no response to and
what that means is when we're at war
that feels like a crisis or right now
we're in the middle of a crisis and it
feels like the government has a role to
play in this so a lot of people are
gonna motivate their vote based on what
the government might do to help them
accept the snap the government is
completely helpless your vote means
nothing it will not bring back your math
teacher who apparently you care a lot
about so democracy would suffer and
because the economy would be in turmoil
for a bit there and people would be kind
of freaking out decent chance that an
authoritarian government actually would
act much faster and kind of kick in
faster and that's what we might be
seeing right now too is that supposedly
some of these authoritarian governments
were able to flatten the curve very
quickly because they were just like stay
home and there yeah we don't got to tell
us twice yeah authoritarian I mean hey
that's what happened in the early 20th
century was Spanish Flu after the huge
depression that hit the industrialized
world after World War one
a lot of fascist regimes rose in that
time because they were able to promise
security and people people bought into
it I mean it's in the New Deal like we
had a depression here in the 30s and FDR
was able to give a lot of power to like
the executive branch away from the
legislative branch just because he was
able to justify it it's like we're in a
national crisis right now and what's
crazy is it worked yeah I mean so so
people wouldn't have these great
arguments against fascism theoretically
because it works uh man I'm just saying
if Thanos did nothing wrong fascism
works I'm doing great here in fact we
actually do have according to Black
Widow in endgame what the government's
real response was to the snap and I
think this shows you how ineffective
they are at helping their immediate
response the governments around the
world was to conduct a census that's
what their response was that's the only
really concrete detail we we got so far
what they did they're counting how many
adults are out there and how many kids
are out there hey Philip a sense this is
a very very important thing and they've
wants to take part in yes the census is
very important post snap a little weird
to deprioritize
but actually I might ride to come up
with like why would they prioritize the
census just cuz like they want to count
to three billion and confirm its own it
is exactly fifty percent how weird I'm
gonna think that what they really mean
by census is they're trying to figure
out one who's gone but two what kids are
suddenly orphaned and literally alone in
their homes so actually imagine that
census workers could be part of this new
workforce part of a new deal just going
out there and knocking on doors and
trying to find children who suddenly
don't have parents at all
so it's not the worst idea if you think
of it that way now what would happen to
these kids right what the government
would do with them we've kind of seen
versions of this both with with
immigrants or relocations of people so
the children would probably get put in
centers that that said there's so many
of them that they'd have to retrofit
other centers so it probably hotels
would get turned into homes for children
to scoop serve to make it 3 I'm not
driving a school school was canceled for
a bit so those would be turned into
homes this is sounding pretty great so
far for the kids
no school live in a hotel I was gonna
say also likely they'd overflow into
private detention centers but that is
kind of how it works but here's what's
interesting then the next step once they
collect all these kids is to try to
relocate them into actual homes and
first they would try to put them in with
relatives right if you have a relative
out there you're gonna go live with them
but there's gonna be so many kids that
they can't find the relative they have
no living relatives their relatives so
yeah my relatives a youtuber that's a
child endangerment right there oh my god
[Music]
what that would result in as they're
trying to get people out of these large
centers is the largest foster care
system we've ever had where millions of
kids are put into foster care and that
might sound terrible when we think about
foster care and all those little kids
singing tomorrow but silver lining here
there would be millions of parents who
have suddenly lost a child and they've
got a child sized hole in their
apartment a bedroom a bed clothes that
they kind of wish they could be making
you so because they've heard the last
kid out of the wall and then ofor I'm
just a hole the size of the kid the kid
ran through the wall really fast but
really like it actually would be this
sweet thing where these two people who
have lost like the most important person
in their life would probably come
together and so adoption rates would
also be higher than they ever have been
so not the worst thing and maybe the
people that are able to adopt again
might sometimes make this is true for a
lot of people sometimes they make better
parents and the ones that had to give
them up of course these people don't
give him up by choice but people that
welcome children into their homes I was
gonna say you
good people but that could go the exact
wrong direction not an it takes two
storied mary-kate and Ashley Olsen there
is the family just kept adopting kids
and made them work at a junkyard
yeah but remember in this scenario it's
just Ashley Olsen so speaking of just
kind of families and human relationships
next up human relationships this is what
I know nothing about although I do know
about awkward relationships and that
actually is the first thing that
immediately happens post snap it's just
so uncomfortable for family to deal with
and not just the death of a family
member I want to even put like the
extreme what if you were doing this what
if you were doing that think of the
simplest version of you're sitting on
your couch watching TV with a family
member and they turn to a pile of dust
that relationship you now have with this
person is so uncomfortable because
you're like literally do I get a dustpan
and have to and scoop them into
something that is a little nicer do I
make sure the cat doesn't see this pile
of dust and make use of it immediate
effects is just so awkward and
uncomfortable and that is probably the
worst moment of everyone livings life
but some time passes and now you've got
kind of some opportunities so actually
if you think about it there's a lot of
new young widows out there a lot of new
young widowers they're looking for
someone who knows what they've been
through and then on top of that not only
is there suddenly a lot of people are
suddenly single and eager to mingle but
dating has never been better
you don't need reservations to go to any
restaurant they're completely available
you can get tickets to Hamilton the
night of and get front-row probably and
they're super cheap it's assuming the
casted and does Philip no hello Broadway
understudies Eric how dare you be such a
snob do you walk out when it's not
lin-manuel I do when I get that insert
in the playbill I tear up the playbill
and I say this is not what I paid for
and then people are like that's a
performance and then you get up on stage
they're like seriously what's the deal
with understudies and then you're
fighting
the with the cellist and he's got that
sword for a whole other reason you have
a fight with this cellist no I won't be
speaking of that by the way they don't
play with the sword it's a sword it's
sharp
[Music]
well then he should tune it alright what
I'm basically saying is dating would be
great and then also this idea of
starting a new people would take this
opportunity to I'm kind of doing this
with what we're going through right now
you kind of get like this blank slate
and you can start over and then you kind
of can see it from mr. Harrington's
wife's perspective where he what
happened with your life this is an
opportunity to kind of start over of
course you don't have to pretend that
you were dusted but she did did I tell
you how my wife pretended to blip out
turns out she ran off with a guy in her
hiking group but a lot of people would
be doing that and basically people would
be living as their authentic selves for
the first time and I mean to the extreme
a whole segment of the population would
become hedonistic as hell we're talking
like hedonismbot fed on grapes sucking
off pineapples I apologize for nothing
there would be n times level of partying
right end of the world kind of parties
and that sounds hella fun as long as
everyone is playing by the same rules in
there all game and it doesn't get too
out of control because you know
historically speaking debauchery stage
get out of your cellist I'm not talking
to you use your sword
I'm just saying debauchery is not always
safe for everybody sometimes it's just
throw away in Sodom and Gomorrah boy oh
boy oh boy is that what it is Gomorrah
why kamorin that's why I my mind always
mixes up Gomorrah in nebulas name even
though I know there's I know who is who
was just like the bad one is nebula
which is confusing because Gomorrah is
the more good character but she's
associated with a biblically bad fit
yeah how funny would it be if Thanos was
like my daughter's Gomorrah and sodomy
like I'm still stirring robot that's the
snap and I think we kind of understand
what a lovely place to live in if you
are one of the lucky 50 fifties if the
gangs haven't seized your property and
murder to you by now sure there's no
gangs everybody came together into one
peaceful gang called the human race or
the gang bank in the hedonistic parties
but also great now let's talk about the
ramifications of three billion people
coming back all of a sudden at a
moment's notice in the speed of a snap
the blip it doesn't go well we're gonna
start bad and we're just gonna get worse
so first let's just talk about these and
some people are just asking about these
a lot just these little weird
uncomfortable scenarios and these are
some of the ones that have kind of bit
address so like the environment I'm
coming to go through these quickly we
saw that basketball team kind of
suddenly reappear with the marching band
yeah I in spider-man they called it the
blimp so that tells us that you returned
the last location you were in a lot of
people are like what if you were in the
middle of a surgery and you're suddenly
back there and you're you have a gaping
hole and you bleed out and you die the
famous one what if you were in a plane
and that planes not there anymore when
you reappear this has been answered by
the Russos has been confirmed just on
the marble side Hulk's nap was not
everybody come back it's everybody come
back real safely specifically a safe
return for the people that came back but
there's no way that the Hulk went
through every scenario and was like you
know so let's not make it like awkward
or uncomfortable for anyone they just
said safe so let's stay on that plane
one for a second right you were in the
air you suddenly a brought back but it
knows well you'll die if you stay there
let's even just conclude the logical
next place let's take him there gate of
destination at the airport that they
were headed to imagine half the people
that were on a plane so was that 200
people 250 people so 125 people suddenly
in one moment appear matta gate all at
once which probably already has a whole
planes worth of people ready to leave
not only is it just like a pile of
people like
like people are breaking legs people are
kissing inadvertently and falling in
love and having to leave their families
but I've seen but we could be live
together and I choose us please Kate
one cup of coffee
you can always go to Paris just
please I want to try again I mean our
marriage I hated your hair I hated your
ugly legs your forearms I hated kissing
your lips Dave okay and that's why I
lacked enthusiasm when your [ __ ] was in
my mouth it is just an insane pile of
people think that is happening all over
the place there's no way this is like
the easiest smallest stakes one is one
of the most uncomfortable you got
snapped and you got dusted while you're
on a public toilet no it is safe for you
to sit in someone else's lap on a public
toilet no matter what the teachers say
it is safe but it's not comfy absolutely
I'll say I'll throw it out there 1
million people probably landed on the
lap of somebody else who was already
pooping decent chance the person that
landed on top also pooping you know what
confuses me is just a simple physics of
how you return is it read us ting just
manifesting now occupying the space to
us we're you're not dropping you're just
like a period what if you're inside
someone else in that moment is it just
like the boys and they just splatter
their blood and guts there are gonna be
some implications like that but I'll say
that you're not coming back from the
dust you were because nobody is near
themselves anymore right so much of the
dust we saw went into the wind so it
doesn't like bring it all the way back
it just kind of snaps that person back
got it as a whole unit so let's go back
again to the category that I said matter
more than anything money
the economy the money everyone's back
there should be so many consumers right
no immediately everything gets way worse
okay remember there was there more than
enough housing for all those people that
were left behind and theoretically will
that same amount amount of housing
should still be there so there should be
housing for everyone except millions and
millions of people would blip back into
existence into an apartment or a place
they'd rent that now has new tenants
oh yeah it's like back to the future the
guys who the hell are you a lot of
people shot on site immediately but also
yeah you got snap back what are you
doing to my daughter's better now
considering that it's been five years
right it hasn't even been just few
months it's been five years it's very
very rare for a resident to have a lease
that lasts that long
so almost no one has a scenario where
they are still the tenant of that rental
property yeah all the people not living
in rent-controlled apartments you're
gonna have someone pop into your life
now gun to without driving each other
crazy even in the rent controlled ones
because they didn't read any continue to
renew their lease oh that's right though
the courts would find there would be no
right for that person to keep that home
anymore it's the same thing as if you
faked your death or disappeared or
something after a certain amount of time
the contract is void so you also better
believe that not only do they not have a
home now but also when they're like well
it's fine I'll quickly put a deposit on
a new place all of their assets are at
best frozen that's the best-case
scenario where the bank is like you're
gone we're not giving you this money
unless they had a will or something that
they could give it to their you know
it's not a better case scenario even if
they're not frozen assets even if it's
not a will the redistribution of the
person's individual wealth would go to
other people in five years do you think
those people didn't just spend it you
think they're just like sitting on it
like thank God I knew you would come
back in five years here's all your money
back plus interest no that money's gone
yes definitely we're like their spouse
was the primary earner they're gonna
need that money in order to like exactly
you know keep their life going so it's
like well man they're in a tough spot
this
and that came back they better quickly
get back to work and not mourn except
they don't have a job anymore
there is huge tremendous unprecedented
unemployment they're not gonna get their
old jobs back because either the company
went under because of the snap or the
company had to move on and has since
replaced that employee leads me to what
would immediately happen starvation
what's hard to kick in and this isn't
just because these people are now
homeless and jobless it's because like
you're saying there's not enough food
the demand of the world's food supply
would suddenly double double and demand
but also you might think well we were
saying earlier things cost less because
there's this overabundance of supplies
but it's been five years now so we've
used up that abundance of supplies and
then we stopped manufacturing to that
level of people because we didn't expect
them to come back so there is not enough
supplies we'd run out of nearly
everything immediately and eventually
would catch back up but not in time for
people not to starve also very important
immediately run out of toilet paper
that's a given we saw how quick that
happens just a little somebody sneezed
and it was like my store was sold out of
toilet paper immediately and you might
be thinking Oh Philip is forgetting that
suddenly there's twice as many cows and
pigs and chickens right that there's a
lot of meat suddenly available because
the livestock had been dusted to kind of
it does come back but the amount of time
that passes from farm to table is too
long to keep someone alive if they
literally have nothing to eat and it's
even worse than normal because remember
there's so much less infrastructure now
less employees less equipment they can't
actually handle this tremendous time
when they have too much of it they
usually have to actually put those
animals down they got to put it down or
they got to throw it away or they got a
yeah they need people to process and
ship it yeah I saw somebody throw a cow
away in the dumpster recently yeah that
cow is being a huge hassle yeah we're
like out of food immediately at least
they have their loved ones back no
personal relationships families they
don't their spouses have also like their
jobs moved on
many of these people in five years
remember I said dating would be amazing
and there's people looking for love
again many of these people have now
remarried and suddenly their original
spouse returns and might think well like
you know I was there first or something
this has actually happened before in the
United States even during wartime a
number of soldiers are declared dead or
missing in action they stop looking for
them people get remarried and then the
person comes back and it gets very
complicated there actually isn't a clear
answer to it you have to deal with it
and you can't pick both because legally
you're not allowed to be married to more
than one person at a time
so either way a beautiful love filled
marriage is ruined one way or the other
yeah I mean think about it five years
later we knew someone who didn't move on
and was still just hoping that some
Avengers might figure out a way to turn
back time we've call those people crazy
yeah move on with your life like it
sucks but it's been five years now Karen
it was two weeks and you already have a
new husband I mean remember also those
sweet adopted kids who found a kind of
adoptive parent and recreated a new bond
that they needed they're in even worse
situation about this now because
suddenly a kid appears in this bedroom
was like who the hell are you he also
has a shotgun what are you doing in my
room
wearing my clothes calling my parents
mom and dad and those kids themselves
who have now come to find this wonderful
parent who took them in spent five years
bonding with them those kids the courts
would find they're still technically
custody to their original parents who
are now back so they will all be
gathered up there'll be trucks they'll
be SWAT teams it'll be like the Elian
Gonzales case exactly like that busting
in because the kid wants to stay and
they're gonna rip them out of an
auntie's arms and send them back to his
creepy old long dusty uncle who's
younger than they should be who's not
ready to take care of kids and just
staying here in these tragic family
situations it gets worse Eric Wow okay
this one's so bad I hate this
implication but it would totally happen
the snap has been undone it's now the
blip they're coming back the three
billion people are coming back a part of
you I'm getting goosebumps even just
thinking about this right
just like holy crap it's all done my
Daniel is coming home to me except
there's gonna be so many instances where
people died because of the snap as a
result of the snap but not that they
were dusted but that something happened
because of that perfect example the
post-credits scene of infinity war that
helicopter slamming into that building
28 people dead probably oh we undid the
snap the Hulk brought everybody back
it's like oh my god Daniel he's back oh
no he didn't like undo like funny deaths
he only undid the dusty ones yes so are
these people gonna get their hopes up
exactly their work hard or just the the
diseases that weren't able to be treated
or like you know people might have taken
their own lives from the depression and
the years that followed like all the
residual effects stay gone did Hulk
think about all of those probably not
he's thinking about like do they sell
triple extra-large cardigans that
technically is all of those kind of
categories those high-level things but I
also asked in our discord if anybody had
some specific questions so staying here
on this family theme for a second
somebody was like well what about the
conjoined twins do they go way together
do they come back together this is
really tough if it is separate you know
you would say that they have two souls
and if we think this is soulstone base
then the souls counting them as two
people a lot of times conjoined twins
share organs and ethos isn't really
thinking when he snaps okay let's give
one of those all of the organs and the
other one let's say that one doesn't own
any of the organs it just rents if one
does dust away first of all that one
goes to dust this one who remains dies
most likely shortly after if their vital
organs their livers suddenly gone or
their heart is suddenly gone right so
this one dusts away and then the blip
happens and the other one comes back but
they are missing vital organs because
the other one died years ago five years
ago so now they immediately die too
I'm mad at the person who asked this
question that was Ruby on discord I like
your Ruby I'm mad at you as to it but I
will give you that it is possible
if we just you have to you it's gonna be
bad news either way but if we say
conjoined twins have no soul or they or
they only share one then you could see
that the snap looks at it in a
scientific way and it's like well they
share an outer layer of skin they share
blood vessels they share DNA cells
interchange between the two of them it
could see them as one entity and snap
them all away and snap it all back or
blip it all back you know we got a hope
for that one but in that one again
they're sharing one soul at best another
weirdo question here this one's from
Marius and perfectas from our discord I
was like well what about the people with
a life sentence if they get blip back
today at least now get to go free
there's precedent for this this happened
in Iowa a few years ago someone was
declared legally dead for a minute and
they argued I died and my sentence
literally said life and the court found
now a funny good idea but no you are
back in prison uh no loopholes on a life
sentence yeah if you wake up in your
grave this they're gonna dig you back
back inside when they didn't die when
they dusted they were just like erase
what they did yeah they brought back
especially for them it was instantaneous
right like yeah from their perspective
nothing happened now there's a decent
chance that person just ended up back in
their cell and didn't notice yeah they
didn't end up in their cell for some
reason then they would definitely would
be sending those trucks around
Elian Gonzales and once he picked up
criminal and the other skeleton in there
too and a cello player and then finally
Cody asked this is the one she's
wondered about the most she says what
about pregnant women and their babies Oh
what if only the baby was snapped and
not the mom would the mom suddenly
become pregnant again five years later
Oh gross so this is one of the most
controversial complicated thought
processes I've had in answering anything
on this show the answer depends on
whether or not you believe that Thanos
is pro-life or pro-choice does this
opinion matter or is it like is it well
I think the Living Tribunal is pro-life
or pro-choice it depends on on his
mindset when he did it in the moment the
same way that they say that cults
mindset made sure everyone was safe well
then Dan knows his mindset comes into
play so I don't think it's a surprise to
say danos he's not pro-life right like
that's kind of his whole thing we're
also framing it pro-life or it should be
pro-choice an anti choice right like by
calling it pro-life that's that's just
the term des chose to say we're pro-life
but really we're just talking about
abortion not life just the matter of
abortion well it makes my argument
easier if I say pro-life so no I'm
saying it but his whole argument is that
it is worth killing half the life in the
universe because there aren't enough
resources to fill the bellies of the
already living or the people to be left
behind
so to him it could be a pro-life choice
with literally the word life and he's
still saying nah I choose to kill half
the life to fill those bellies so in
other words he makes a choice to prevent
a potential life from existing any
further if it means that it would be
born into a universe of suffering and
non full bellies I am so uncomfortable
with this line of thinking I know the
dude would definitely be on the
pro-choice argument with the logic that
you could add on that life then probably
begins at birth when the individual
creatures need for resources and
consuming them counts against that new
little baby individual because
previously when it was in it's mommy and
she was eating those resources that
counted as a resource consumption person
now it's two units so this person has to
stand alone and justify their own life
and if that made you way too
uncomfortable and you are real mad now
pretend I didn't say any of that and
I'll just give you this argument
buckey's arm buckey's arm dusts away
along with Bucky right and that's
because we've since learned because of
this mind send the way he defined an
individual if it's part of your identity
it's something that you see as part of
yourself then it also dusts away too and
it's very likely that a pregnant woman
while that baby's in there
feels like that baby's as much part of
her at least as much part of her as
Falcons wings are to him
so in this case it's most likely that a
pregnant mother and the unborn child are
treated as a package deal that both
dusted or they both get blip they both
come back so no creepy suddenly been
eight months pregnant five years later
and that's just not good for anyone
that's definitely a more convenient way
to think about it though and the
leftovers a woman has a baby have sudden
departure from her womb that is
something that some other creative has
has speculated on and it's horrible and
it traumatizes everyone involved but in
the leftovers they left their clothes
behind right no I don't think I might be
thinking of a war of the worlds' with
Tom Cruise or in left behind right left
behind their clothes Oh a pine that's
right that's right
so I sodomy Gomorrah my daughter's I
hope I did you proud it's way worse to
bring everyone back I reason I said Tony
Stark could be a terrorist is because he
was so protective of his family unit
that he said don't change anything else
just bring the people back five years
later don't undo it all just make us
deal with those ramifications of
homelessness and starvation and just
uncomfortable people pooping on top of
another person that's already put my
folks the one who pulled the trigger it
was Bruce Banner who did it he's the
terrorist he's the one who's he was
following orders it's just following
orders
he's got a simple brain and he's just
like safely safely
hopefully oh my god what it what a
horrible decision the Avengers made
becoming smart Hulk is probably still
dumber than just normal Bruce Banner
because you're clumsy and why would you
want to live like that
you can't ever put on socks again I'm a
tall little person medium oh no I think
young fan notes from 2014 ooh hoo they
fighted the finale of Avengers endgame
he's the one who had it right he's like
you know what this is such a freaking
mess now I'm just gonna tear the
university shreds and start over and
they won't know anything that happened
never tell them ever to yeah it's a
miserable place it's no wonder that they
have to skip a lot of time and just kind
of let stuff get figured out off-screen
alright Eric I ate up all of the time so
I'm gonna give you one bite-sized
question okay fair enough this question
comes from master man Alex on our
discord in lost you got another lost
cause Jeff why do people think the flash
sideways is purgatory yeah I saw this
and I get your frustration Alex because
yeah a lot of people I think
oversimplify the final season of Lost
what's up you stand on this Philip I
thought was underappreciated I thought
the final season a loss is fine but just
to remind people in the final season
lost all of reality split into two
parallel timelines we weren't really
sure what's gonna I was kind of a
Schrodinger experiment we had the main
events on the island where they
condensed all the time-travel crap on
the island they're all in the president
and then like a flash sideways
hypothetical timeline in which a chanock
815 never crashed like they landed at
LAX and they all have these like
different lives like jack has a son but
then the finale episode reveals that
that flash sideways timeline was really
this like cosmic limbo realm that
existed outside of time that was created
so that all these souls could find each
other to reconnect before they move on
to the next phase you know to remember
and to let go the reason why I think a
lot of people hated this is because
earlier in the series The Lost riders
were adamant that the island is not
purgatory being on the Cylons a metaphor
and it is that in some way so I like
that
you know that isn't literally what it is
that was like the big fan theory that
they were asked from season one and
they're like no it's not purgatory and
it was that tone but a lot of people are
like okay so they must have something
completely different in mind that's not
at all religious it's not gonna be this
other realm that's similar to purgatory
because they were so in denial about it
being purgatory they were like it's
purgatory right
they're all dead and we kept saying we
swear to god they are not all dead and
while this whole thing wouldn't it being
it it is it exactly purgatory no one
calls it purgatory
especially based off of what we know
about purgatory from Catholic theology
and Dante's Divine Comedy the concept of
purgatory is it's more of a something
rooted in Catholicism in all of
Catholicism is is metaphorical and
interpretive it's not one of the
literalists branches of Christianity by
any means so it's kind of like a poetic
interpretation of what might happen with
certain Souls when they die so the fact
that this finale is kind of AD and it
took place in a church like the final
scene was in a church there was imagery
from a lot of denominations there is
judeo-christian so there was there was a
lot of different imagery in there but it
was in a trickster sitting in pews like
for a lot of people that is undeniably
purgatory this idea you're gonna have
like an additional life to work off some
of the problems with your soul and to
work through some of your ongoing
problems that is by definition a lot of
people's minds purgatory or at least
it's too close to what people understand
purgatory to be that they felt misled by
the writers and Damon Lindelof the the
lost ocean runner have later admitted
that he wouldn't do anything differently
with the way they wrote lost they could
have been better about expectation
management and that some of the problems
with lost were some of the the mysteries
and promises that they made on the
fringes of the show as opposed to what
story they're actually telling that they
created this whole other meta narrative
that fans started to latch on to and
that took over the show and that was
honestly by their own mistakes for doing
that and little off like a lot of people
say always sucks
this guy is went on to do the leftovers
which if you're into like the snap
locations applications the leftovers
amazing and Watchmen like this guy is a
really really good TV show runner but he
definitely
stumbled in some ways on lost including
the promises they made with that final
season and he was kind of abandoned
right it wasn't even his idea initially
it was a JJ Abrams show and he left it
was JJ Abrams did set up a lot of those
mysteries from early on but it was Damon
Olaf who said it was not purgatory yeah
but I also say and it is purgatory and
that's the answer to the question is
that that's why people think it's
purgatory it's all real it all happened
everything happened
I'll also just remind you in terms of
where I land on it the issue isn't that
it's an interesting ending and an
interesting final season it's that all
the other mysteries are kind of just
like oh I mean we don't have to answer
those and it's like those are the ones
we spend four seasons on our five
seasons on yeah yeah yeah all right so
that's our bite size so then it's time
for the question Bob yes the grid cube
of questions sometimes raises questions
they're just statements that we have
thoughts on this one is scratched onto a
Clorox wipe there's so many other things
you could use that for you find a
blacklight places look like a Jackson
Pollock painting person wants to know
try the Russ have you ever been a member
of rising have you ever been stuck in a
holding pattern and if so what did you
do to get out of it all add successfully
or unsuccessfully I had to look up
actually a while ago what a holding
pattern was because I just imagine like
you're just like holding your nuts as
you're trying to figure out what to do
next like in a in a pattern combination
left left right right up up downtown
like you're naked in the middle of like
a crowded city block and you're like
which door do I try holding batter is
like when a plane is just circling over
an airport and they're like you can't
land yet so just kind of hang out here
and then we'll tell you where to land
the pilots just holding his nuts
I'm sure you feel this way too Phillip
like it's a lot of parts of my life
we're looking back on I was like I was
between phases there and I'm just kind
of like drifting and I don't really know
what the next move was but like there's
always somewhere where you land on the
other side of it and the go-to period
for my life is like in 2015 my apartment
burned I was suddenly homeless it was a
building next door it was a construction
site went up in a matter of seconds
there's a huge drought so everything was
super dry and then our
it's completely unlivable and I was in
this weird place where I was completely
stable had the same job the same routine
for like years and years and it's
suddenly I was homeless really I was
fine I was able to salvage a lot of my
stuff
I didn't get injured no one I knew got
hurt or died thank God but worst part of
it was I was just in this like floaty
space where it's like okay well I know
I'm gonna find a place to live but it's
like halfway through the month so I'm
gonna have to sleep on people's couches
for like three weeks and all right I'll
just figure it out I guess and I gotta
get all new stuff and uh you know so
it's just like it just sucked because
like I I didn't I wasn't hurt so bad
that like I could really complain to
people every conversation I was in I was
like well it could have been worse it
could have been worse yeah I could have
died yeah yeah so like I just hated
being in that pattern of just like
having the same conversation over and
over again I'm fine I'm okay and I
didn't deal with it properly really like
I probably should have yeah no it was a
trauma there's a trauma but like I feel
like I'm not waking up in the middle of
the night I didn't fully understand what
stress and anxiety are I think at the
time I didn't understand that like
anxieties this creeping thing that just
like it's always with you and it twists
your emotions in a way that attack you
and you feel guilty for feeling certain
ways and that is a form of anxiety so
the way I process at the time is I wrote
this long essay that just like processed
all of my feelings on and this whole
like three-week period and you know just
like thanking everyone for helping me
out and then shortly after that I did
something I don't normally do I went out
to a friend's birthday party at a bar I
don't normally like going to bars for
birthdays like especially if they're
like in a part of town I don't normally
go to I might give your childhood yeah I
grew up at a bar I lived on borrow is
Don Draper essentially live in Bravo but
just doing that I ended up meeting a
girl one no longer this is a completely
different girl friend years ago but
because like at that point my life I
felt like I wasn't allowed to get nice
things because they might burn like I
had was in this weird state that like I
was super immaterial and I was like I'm
not gonna get nice clothes because like
I don't want to have to just like pay
for somebody might lose yeah so I was
just like as this date place where I
felt like I didn't deserve nice things
so the first attention I got like I
latched on
- this person thinking that she was
going to like rest I was like a rescue
dog I was like yes please and I was in
this lake it wasn't a terrible toxic
relationship breathing but we were not
right for each other it was like the
first like serious relationship I was in
for a while and I found out like other
things later she's like the truth or an
anti-vaxxer like always it's like I just
know she likes Superman like I work
through this I just ignored those things
thinking like this is like my life now
because I didn't fully process like this
big revolutionary thing in my life
luckily it ended she ended it you know
kudos to her recognizing that it wasn't
right and I went through a period of
depression after that and I did properly
deal with it but then I end up like
understanding the the fleeting nature of
home and I ended up turning that into
like the best movie script I've ever
written this whole idea of like you
can't really ever go home again
so like home like Asgard is a people not
a place basically I ragnar act myself my
home burned down then I the getting a
gaining weight and then I was fine on
the other side of it it's funny that's
the Eric that's you don't know this
that's the theme of the current script
I'm working on exactly that phrase you
can never go home again
yeah we all we all get there right yeah
yeah exactly you feel at some point
really telling the way you just
described anxiety a moment ago the big
guilt you had over your own thoughts
yeah but it's not just the invasive
thoughts
it's then feeling terrible about them
which is just a spiral they fall down
yeah it's like me for feeling this way I
don't deserve to feel like if my life is
relatively fine but yeah my thoughts
aren't valid right yeah yeah suffering
is relative though you know I think it's
we're gonna remember like your inner
pain is valid and you need to you need
to work through it you know I can't just
ignore that I had a different story that
I was thinking of where about like
trying to move out to LA and how hard
that was but you you just reminded me of
I kind of hinted at this before so it's
kind of more true than the other side of
Intel but there was a time in college I
knew you then I just wasn't too public
about it where I was 100% homeless I had
nowhere to live for four months and I
did a little bit of couch to couch and I
literally slept in Walmart
I slept in a tent really when I could
yeah in the in the 24 because it was
only 24-hour place and so there was
nowhere to be that you could be up that
late so yeah I would go into Walmart at
night and I would see the greeter and I
would say you would be gone in the snap
like what is the snap and I was like
it's a dance craze but no I uh yeah I
would try to sleep in the tent try not
to get caught I usually didn't and then
eventually one of a just another friend
who like knew how bad shape OHS and let
she was like I don't have space but I
have a car and so she let me live in her
car for a while and so that was just
absolutely like a very dark stretch of
time but also I mean talk about a
holding pattern right I was I also I was
kicked out of school because I couldn't
pay for it anymore um so just like so
what do I even what do I even do like I
know I shouldn't go back to Miami
because that's what put my family in a
situation where I'm in this situation
and I'm trying to escape that so if I go
back there I'm just gonna relive these
same mistakes and lead to the same thing
so it's like I can't go back but I also
can't go forward I literally can't
afford to so then I started doing this
thing where because I had nowhere to go
at night I know we're good during the
day but during the day even though I was
technically kicked out of school I would
just go to lecture halls and just sit in
on classes that were like in that
lecture hall all day so like the one in
Weimar all right and I would take
classes that I wasn't taking and just
that but that I was just like interested
in one of them was television in
American society yeah and I was like
vaguely getting interested in becoming a
writer or working in TV and media and
things like that and so you know what
they don't they're not checking ID at
that no one here oh no yes idiots yeah
they are now that's the same lecture
hall that I puked in at one time oh they
had to tear out the floor but I I would
sit in there and I would take notes
because I was like you know studying to
learn the content of the class and I
would ask questions and everything and I
was like hey I'm a student in this class
I would have this question and then
eventually I guess like there was this
girl who actually ended up becoming a
really good one of her friends but she
would notice I was taking all these
great notes and so she started asking
for my notes and then other people would
ask for my notes and then I have a
little a little devil on my shoulder and
then I have
dollar sign on the other shoulder and
they come together sometimes all right
and I was like I could sell these notes
so I started selling my notes to the
class that I wasn't even taking and then
you know in order to make some real
money with this cuz I got to think you
know you got a scale that's the
important thing
money is the most important things I've
always been taught money and then
breakfast so I started selling my notes
to a tutoring company that helped people
study for the exams so they would sell
like my notes and I was beat I was a
published writer all of the sudden and I
was so excited about this I started
going so I started making the most money
I'd ever made which is nothing and still
it was just Gainesville Florida college
student but enough money where I was
able to afford a bedroom in somebody's
house so I suddenly like wasn't homeless
anymore I got you a job doing the same
thing I worked there yeah yeah and you
used it to buy a new Rolex burned it
started a fire I tried to live in the
box that it came in but so I did kind of
like start to relive this life and then
I never actually got to sign up for
classes again because they were so
expensive but I was still doing that
thing where I was kind of fake going to
classes and then I realized I have
access in that same College to equipment
through friends that I could I could
kind of steal but kind of borrow the
equipment and then so that's what I
ended up happening at the end of our
time at UF where I kind of created a
film major that they didn't have and a
comedy major that they didn't have and I
used all their facilities and all their
equipment I had a job so I like milk
that school for as much as I could do it
but good honestly I thought like I
needed that that money back and I got
out of the rut that I was in by you know
I think I'd been waiting for somebody to
pull me out like my family to show up
and rescue me or something but instead I
just like found these ways to kind of
make my own opportunities and then you
know build a ladder with them to climb
out of it myself and that's I mean
that's the same thing that I even do now
that's that's what new rock stars was
you like that's the one of the only ways
out is kind of you're like doing it
yourself you know what I mean you have
and and but I also I'm gonna say before
you know I hope that some people like do
think that because I'm very aggressive
about the amount of control you have
over your own
and power you have but I think that's
actually a good segue because sometimes
you still feel powerless anyway it and
it's it's not it is harder than just you
need to buck up and put your life
together or something right um so we
we've been talking about when we wanted
to do this and it just feels like an
important thing to say while we're going
through all of this together but also
separately so we just want to talk about
I'm just kind of what's going on in the
world but also just this thing that it's
it's probably more important than ever
that you be spending time with each
other in whatever way you can
yeah like we're watching this is like
the perfect time to text not just a
friend that you are already texting the
co-worker you're still kind of working
with remotely but text afrien you
haven't seen in a while or you know you
do it yourself schedule the Xoom happy
hour do you think it'd happen or call
your balance game everyone call your mom
please play checkbox with your mom her
so funny so dirty yeah just let the
people in your life know that you're
thinking about them and also if that you
need them somebody messaged me today
saying that they they just needed to let
somebody know that they weren't doing
great I was like I like that's brave to
tell me and I'm I'm like happy that you
are brave enough to admit that to
yourself because that's the first step
the next thing is now seeking help if it
turns out you can't help yourself I have
here if you feel like it has nobody to
help you it's I think it's Nami is the
way they say but the Nami is the
nation's largest grassroots version of a
mental health organization um and they
can help get you support if you need it
they can teach you how to be a support
system for other people if you just want
to find another way to help May which
were technically kind of done with
whatever but this was Mental Health
Awareness Month is one of the reasons
why we want to talk about this and Nami
just has a ton of great resources for
dealing with mental health issues
especially right now and the current
state of everything so you can go to
Nami org so I'll put the website on the
screen but it's Nami dot o-r-g or you
can also call one eight hundred nine
five zero Nami which is six to six for
the 1-800 nine five zero six two six
four just call them it's like super easy
you're just it's nice to talk to
somebody you're not alone even though it
feels like it
right alright well I think that's a
great place to wrap things up for this
week
that is our show so reminder that you
can join our official discord by
becoming a patron at patreon.com slash
new rockstars and you can get audio
versions of the show by subscribing to
new rockstars big question wherever you
get your podcasts and thanks so much to
everyone who submitted questions this
week if you we didn't get your question
in this week we'll definitely get it on
in the future week you can send us your
big questions on twitter using the
hashtag big question by mailing us at
our p o-- box or yeah joining us on
discord it's probably we're gonna see
your question first you'll follow me at
EI vos follow Phillip at Phillip Molina
and follow me rock stars on social media
and subscribe here on YouTube to get it
too much information on all the stuff
that you care about thanks everyone see
you next week take care of yourselves
Claire mom call your she's hilarious
[Music]